premier documentaire sur lequel j'ai
commencé à travailler c'est sûr françois
pavilla françois pavilla pourquoi
françois pavilla parce qu'il a été un
personnage romantique emblématique donc
de des années 60 en france et au travers
de cette histoire emblématique de héros
de la boxe
nous évoquons la petite histoire mais la
grande
c'est à dire l'intégration dont de ces
jeunes antillais qui viennent en france
dans les années 50 pour avoir trouvé une
je dirais une nouvelle une nouvelle vie
et dans cette nouvelle vie c'est que
c'est aussi socialement essayez donc de
monter dans la hiérarchie sociale et la
boxe
d'une certaine manière permet à ces
jeunes antillais à venir en france et
c'est cette histoire qu'on nous allons
raconter l'histoire donc de ce françois
pas villa qui part dans les années 50
fin des années 50 on est à la fin donc
du processus colonial et toutes les
prises de conscience politique se met en
place pour la décolonisation
on se retrouve en france je dirais poste
première deuxième guerre mondiale post
colonisation et la france soient pas
villa va évoluer dans le milieu sportif
parisien et va montrer qu' il est
totalement différent donc des autres
boxeurs et par sa pertinence et sa
dynamisme va être effectivement un
boxeur qui va émerger sur un point venu
médiatique mais au niveau 6 au niveau
sportif
alors pour réaliser un tel film vous
avez besoin de certains noms de
le document est ce que vous les avez
tout ça on n'a jamais tous les documents
toutefois il ya la famille pas villa
dispose de documents exceptionnels
je dirais pratiquement tout son parcours
a été a donc archives et photos films
également affiche ce qui déjà donne une
matière première
deuxièmement pas ville a été beaucoup
filmé donc il ya eu de nombreux
reportages radio qui a été fait à
l'époque par michel drucker mais
également des reportages qui ont été
faits à la télévision en noir et blanc
en super 16 qui ont été diffusées et
également nous avons effectivement
claude lelouch s'est intéressée
effectivement l histoire de pas villa
dans le film vivre ensemble avec annie
girardot et montant et pavie l'afld donc
à fait partie donc d'une séquence
importante donc du film où on voit pas
ville à boxer ça veut dire que pas
vilain autrement dit a été un des
personnages clés de la boxe française
pendant une période assez courte entre
60 et 68 où il
tout le monde donc du sport et du
spectacle s'est retrouvé autour de pavie
là nous avons besoin de rechercher de
témoin
ça c'est la première chose qui nous
permet donc de pouvoir avoir un regard
effectivement complémentaire donc de la
construction de ce film deuxièmement ce
que nous avons besoin c'est que je
recherche un jeune enfant de 10 à 11 ans
qui aime la boxe et qui pourrait
ressembler un peu à pavie là pour créer
effectivement une séquence
docu fiction et puis nous cherchons
aussi également des archives ou des
contenus qui pourrait avoir été filmées
par des amateurs
à l'époque pour le dernier match qui a
eu lieu en 60 ans mais 67 qui a été
énormément médiatisé mais dont on n'a
que des photos et j'aimerais
effectivement savoir si il y à une
personne qui dispose je dirais
d'archives/reuters perdre 8 ou 8 mm que
nous pourrions éventuellement introduire
dans le documentaire